well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages
in the next half hour we'll see what's
making the headlines with the consultant
editor
of the daily mail andrew pearce and the
associate editor
of the daily mirror kevin mcguire great
to see you andrew i thought the
technology had defeated you for a while
there
i couldn't find me volume and you know i
like
i know kevin doesn't want to hear the
sound of my voice but um anyway
i found it eventually yes your audience
does obviously i might i couldn't find
the knob
right good tonight
let's look at the front pages shall we
starting with the financial times it
leads with
the agreement by the uk and the eu to
work together on ensuring each other's
vaccines apply in a move that may ease
diplomatic tensions
here's the expresses headline at last
euc
sense in jab rao the metro points out
that
before the statement was released bruce
johnson cautioned
that the eu's refusal to export any of
its stock
could prompt businesses to stop
investing there
the telegraph understands the prime
minister intends to let
individual publicans decide for
themselves whether patrons will have to
prove they don't have covid
or have been vaccinated same lead story
for the male
vaccine passport to go to the pub
likewise the sun which splashes with
no jab no pint and the times two kovid
jab needed to enter pubs
the headline for them the guardian
leading with what experts have called an
incredible
injustice for pupil for pupils rather
from minority ethnic backgrounds
who have been excluded at far higher
rates than other children
on a different note the star suggesting
that pollution is causing a certain part
of men's anatomy to shrink
oh we end where we started
oh no i'm going to stop there andrew
pearce
um so pubs let's cheer ourselves up uh
kind of
um so you can only go possibly um
if you prove you haven't got covid or
you've had a vaccination
andrew your thoughts well
look you know i i try to be libertarian
about things but
i think it's uh an economic reality this
is going to be
the way forward for many many businesses
people want to go back to the pub
mcguire and i will no doubt find pubs
with a garden on
april the 12th uh where you can sit
outside and have a pint but um
republicans already
can bar people for all sorts of reasons
they may not like the cuts of their jib
they may be a bit drunk they may think
they're not old enough and i think it's
a logical thing now for them to say
have you had the vaccine uh are you in
the clear if you've got an exclusion so
be it
but i think it's just economic reality i
was talking to a great friend who's
involved in the theater the other day
and she said it's the same for the
theater if they want to get west end
shows back
by god we want to get performing arts
back
almost certainly they're going to have
to say you've got to show
that you are covered free because it's
going to deter other people from going
to the theater
it's going to deter other people from
going to the pub and
i know it's going to produce house of
protest from the libertarian wing
of britain but i'm afraid i don't have
any great
objections to this if it means we can
get pubs back in business
making money doing what they do best
serving pint serving good food all well
and good because they've had a terrible
terrible year and the same rule i think
is going to apply to restaurants as well
yeah i mean it it's true everybody wants
to go with confidence don't they to a
location
certainly it's the lead for the daily
telegraph too this all came out in the
liaison committee
at the heads of the select committees
asking the prime minister's questions it
does feel a bit like policy on the hoof
though doesn't it
and once again gives the owners to other
organizations be it
care homes for insisting that staff
there have jabs
or publicans uh for ensuring covert
vaccines
or a negative test um is it right that
the government
leaves it to these individual
organizations do you think kevin
well i know the telegraph has a poll
saying it's popular by
people by 56 to 17 think proving you
don't have covert to get in the pub
is a is a good idea but you're quite
right about
boris johnson he lurches uh around more
than a paralytic drunk uh
chucked out after an all-day bender uh
one day he'll back something the next he
won't ministers always contradict
each other so you don't know if it's
just a throwaway line a bit of bar
talk you you have some space to fill up
the committee
or whether it's a serious uh runner
but if it is a serious runner just
leaving it
to republicans to landlords as you say i
think would feel
a bit book passing by the prime minister
when you're you basically are
introducing a
form of a passport show your papers to
getting a pub i don't think it's
necessarily
wrong uh right from the beginning even
before i had the job myself i thought if
this is how you open up
whether it's theaters cinemas sports
grounds pubs
cafes restaurants whatever it is if you
have the jab
and you can go in because you will be
safe and the staff
must also be safe too and i couldn't see
what was
what was wrong with it over a period of
time but he's going to get a
kicking from some of his own party and i
do
you should reinforce it with legislation
in some way if
it's going to happen well can i just say
that look i think we're all a bit sick
to death of the government telling us
everything we can and can't do
i know we've had to do that to get the
lockdown sorted out and
the government took extraordinary
emergency powers the opposition went
along with it but we are easing out of
lockdown now
and let people make their own decisions
kevin we don't have to have the
government deciding
every single thing for us legislating on
everything
no more legislation please no more rules
and dictators from the government
let the market decide let public comment
restaurateurs decide
let them make their own decisions if
they decide they don't need
you don't need identification in that
club you watch how many people who go to
that pub
not very many i'll tell you what that
happened andrew if you just leave it
to pubs it'll be a landlord or a
landlady says we're going to operate
this said you're going to get a group of
lads possibly a bit worse for wear being
a bit boisterous
be locked out of pubs for a long time
turn it up
and when it's just but it's anyway
when it's just the word of the landlord
it'll kick off
if it's the law they are more likely to
respect it because then the police
could be called and can intervene that's
why that's why johnson needs the courage
of his convictions if he's going to go
down this
don't keep passive responsibility you
know he does that he
always wants to pass the blame to
somebody else oh
i fundamentally disagree with that
there's a poll shows today that the 18
to 34 year olds are the group most
likely to completely ignore the rules
now
and we're still in the thick of the
pandemic they won't care about what the
government says or what the law says
you've seen them how many young people
are gathering in great
groups and crowds whether it's on a
field or on hampshire heath or wherever
you are
we saw what it was like in soho before
the last lockdown andrew they don't
care yeah this this leads to so many
questions who doesn't need the
government to tell them yeah
this leads to so many questions though
for republicans for them to decide
what do you call vaccinated i mean saga
holidays i made note
means two vaccines plus one week that
means nobody's going inside a pub for a
very long time actually
does it mean which sort of testing does
it mean lateral flow testing
does it mean pcr testing if so are you
going to make that more available to
people what are you going to do about
staff will they be tested every day
i mean it goes on these questions
doesn't it we've got to learn to live
with it anna so we just have to find a
way through it this wretched thing isn't
going to disappear
in june when the lockdown is lifted
finally it's going to be with us for a
very long time it's going to be back in
the autumn back in the winter with a
vengeance
we've seen what's happening all across
europe we've got to learn to live with
it but it doesn't mean we have to have
the government deciding every single
thing for us we can be grown up about it
and we're going to have to find a way
through this because otherwise we are
never going to be able to leave our
homes we're never going to be able to go
back to work
never know to go on a coach or bus again
you've got to get a grip
the sun says boo's a shock just quickly
as well the guardian
um suggests that if if the pubs can use
a covered passport
they could do away with social
distancing that is big economic impact
for them obviously doesn't it because it
means more
more people can get inside a pub so that
that's also important
it is that it means you can get the bomb
by buy a drink and not that
uh until pierce has ever been to a bar
uh to buy a drink i've been in a pool
with him he doesn't need a passport he
needs a map to find that bar
you'll find that you have very very
short arms long pockets
once again at the toilet or just gets
lost and you'd you'd die
you'd die a thirst if you waited for it
to buy it by a drink
but you're right if you know one of the
one of the problems landlord
is if you have all these controls inside
you're going to have fewer tables it's
very hard to get a pub to be
economically viable
uh and i want pubs to save as possible
and if people are validated
everybody's vaccinated then they will be
a lot safer than if people are going in
unvaccinated um can we squeeze in very
quickly the ft
and the uk and eu trying to calm the row
try to be nice about ursula van der lion
we had complaints about the way you
spoke about her last time andrew
well were they complaining i wasn't rude
enough no no
i'm sorry no i'm so sorry because
she is continuing to preside over utter
chaos utter shambles
eu leaders publicly disowning this woman
uh
she just has to remember she got three
months late
to astrazeneca to sign contracts three
months after the uk
and the astrazeneca contracts were not
binding in the way britain was
they were something i think the
expression was best reasonable effort
well they're paying a heavy price now
for the fact their best reasonable
efforts means they haven't been able to
give the eu as many as they wanted
they should all appeal for calm there's
a summit tomorrow but i think calm will
be restored but they should send
ursula vondalen out of the room she's an
idiot
oh god yeah unlike your hero boris
johnson who's a superhuman and presided
over and twenty six thousand
uh plus i think
um gentlemen thank you very much for now
we will see you very shortly
uh coming up an injustice for black
caribbean pupils
talking about that investigation in the
guardian next
[Music]
[Music]
i started pen paling seriously just this
summer
there's a program on twitter called pen
palooza
which was started by the new yorker
writer rachel sein in the summer of last
year
and there are now 12 000 people
participating so
that's how i started pen paling but uh
we
it's evolved since then so
we are being based in dublin we are
still in lockdown
so uh the pen pals allow me to kind of
travel
and see parts of the world that you know
one hopes they would get to go to
uh just yesterday i was sending um pen
pal letters to
germany uh canada and england
so it's really exciting to just be able
to send a couple thoughts and you know
maybe some stickers to someone around
the other side of the world and just
tell them i'm thinking of them
especially as we're all isolating and in
lockdown the pandemic has certainly
reminded a lot of people that maybe
the way they were you know allocating
their days before
lockdowns and isolations and things
wasn't the healthiest
uh and i think that's why pen palooza
and pen palling has been such a success
because people are really enjoying
taking the time at the end of the day or
on a saturday or a sunday or
you know maybe before work and just
saying you know hey i'm thinking of you
and i really think that if everyone just
sat down today and wrote a letter
the world would be a much kinder place
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based
in delhi
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now andrew pearce
and kevin mcguire welcome back to both
of you a lot to pack in
lots on the front page of the guardian
uh you wanted to mention first of all
the headline
exclusion rates for black caribbean
students in english schools
are up to six times higher than those of
their white peers and some local
authorities
gypsy roma and traveller children also
excluded at much higher rates with roma
children
nine times more likely to be suspended
in some areas an important story for uh
on that we'll talk about that at half
11. you also want to talk about flags
they're flying from buildings
they've decided to kevin um show the
prime minister
with his uh flags
the last refuge of the scoundrel
politicians wrap them up themselves up
in flags when they probably don't want
us to
talk about those exclusion figures for
instance other more important issues
in one way i have no objection to public
buildings that fly in the union flag and
in many ways i wondered why they
happened for a long time
you can have your national flag too you
could have the eu
flag back in the day you might have a
county flag but i think coming
coming in with it now this government is
just obsessed
with uh flags at the moment there was
one idiot tory mp
who was on the go at the head of the bbc
saying why were there no flags in the
last annual report
and somebody pointed out there are no
flags in the last tory
oh yeah manifesto mean the bloke looked
a complete
uh plunker as a as a as a result but
this is going to be very provocative
though i think the flags
in somewhere like scotland and why do i
just don't think at the moment it will
increase
why is it provocative and by the way
he's not boris isn't the first prime
minister to do this kevin's mate gordon
brown did this
when he was in his first six months of
his premiership and actually
miss sturgeon has taken down um the
union flag
except on uh remembrance remembrance day
in scotland and stuck up the european
union flag which is really stupid and
pathetic
i think it's a good thing to show the
flag good to be patriotic what's wrong
with it and i have one in my
kitchen which i regularly flutter which
hopefully you'll bring out at half
eleven
she said i will obviously um so
let's get to the other picture story
around which is this extraordinary
situation in the sewers canal
the ft's decided to go for the uh for
the for the digger
um looking very tiny um against the
bulging part of the ship at the front
which i've now forgotten
its official name may well be sort of
sunk underneath the prowess it
sunk actually underneath the part of the
sewers canal completely blocked it is
amazing this isn't it
yeah the front of the ship's the bow is
that the world you were looking for is
there another the bulgy bit on a super
tanker is is
anyway not i'm told it's the prism
yeah we're not very shipshape on this
are we really yeah but
yeah the ft though do you have the just
the size of these vessels
it says it's almost as long as the
empire state building is
high and it's that's 400 meters that's
about four football pitches
50 59 meters wide maybe it's a surprise
this hasn't happened a bit more often
when you look at you look at the size of
these because they get
blown off course or knocked off course
it's very very difficult to
uh to write them but that canal
is uh it's an absolute lifeline for the
world trade 120 miles long 50 vessels uh
dear 10 of all sea trade absolutely
incredible
british flag i normally want vessels to
be british flag but i'm glad this one's
not
well i just got to say you've got to
feel a little bit sorry for the skipper
because i suspect he's not going to get
his bonus this month because that is one
hell of a problem
it's the um bulbous bow apparently we
will see them at
half eleven thank you
[Music]
for the early risers as we examine the
story beyond the headline
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
entertainment podcast but wherever you
are welcome to
the safety rage for the ones who want to
know more
welcome to the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners
from sky news story cast sky news
podcasts
listen and subscribe for free
[Music]
you